père part à la martinique des
possibilités d'investissement qui se
joue actuellement dominique suite après
la pré maria comment ils se sont remis
quelles sont les nouvelles conditions de
possibilité d'investir en dominique les
différents secteurs qui sont les
secteurs on va dire de l'environnement
de l'hôtellerie du tourisme des énergies
renouvelables pour lequel il propose des
possibilités de construire de faire des
joint-venture du partenariat
et puis aussi nous donner la température
de ce qu'ils ont vécu et c'est ce qui a
été fait et qu'est ce qui ne doit plus
être fait dans leurs futures
constructions dans le la redynamisation
de la dominique ya de plus en plus le
pays roannais les gens ont confiance
par contre un autre souci c'est que pas
mal de gens sont partis
donc la population qui était déjà de
70000 habitants pour l'instant ils
savent pas si c'est 5000 personnes six
et dix mille personnes 15000 personnes
qui ont suis conquis ce qu'ils ont
quitté la dominique pour aller
travailler ailleurs
mais on sent qu'il ya des gens qui
reviennent et qui s'investissent pour
leur pays
les liens avec la guadeloupe sont
existent ils sont là pour certains
informelle mais existent mais a comme
disaient les différents chefs
d'entreprise tout à l'heure que nous
avons rencontrés à contacter
l'entreprise
c'est un peu plus difficile les liens
avec la martinique et c'est ce que
invest dominique a et aussi par le biais
de jean yves bonnet qui est un
martiniquais qui a investi qui est
installé à la dominique depuis 13 ans de
rebooster un petit peu et que les
martiniquais se hasarder sortent de chez
eux pour aller voir quels sont les
pauses le potentiel qui a d'investir à
la dominique